Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to ther seat and beyond it. Rich and poor, young and old, sat shoulder to shoulder, awaiting the message of this new gospel. Some were there from curiosity, some from interest, some from fear. But around and about were thousands, young, eager, and virile, who were there from devotion to their leader, his policy, and the movement. Pride of race, love of country, loyalty, hope,
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 ther seat 及之后的内容。无论贫富、老少，人们肩并肩坐在一起，等待着这则新福音的消息。有些人是出于好奇，有些人是出于利益，有些人则是出于恐惧。但在周围，成千上万年轻人热切而充满活力，他们之所以在那里，是因为对领袖、他的政策以及这场运动的忠诚。种族自豪感、爱国情怀、忠诚、希望，
all these and more were reflected in their ardent faces and shining eyes. For the first time, I realized this was no passing whim no temporary excitement what then was it what was it dominic that was lieutenant colonel sir thomas moore who was the conservative mp for air and he had been in the albert hall in april 19, watching the rally of the British Union of Fascists. Yes. So Tom, our sister podcast, The Rest is Politics, often plays at the Albert Hall, doesn't it? They're very similar enterprises, actually. And you'd enjoy that. Well, yes, but before we get on to kind of venue-based jokes, we should probably wait to see whether the British Union of Fascists ever appeared in venues that we have appeared in. That's true. So Sir Thomas More, I'll tell you
所有这些以及更多情感都反映在他们热切的面孔和闪烁的眼睛里。我第一次意识到，这绝非一时兴起，也不是暂时的兴奋。那么，这到底是什么？多米尼克，那个人是谁？那是托马斯·摩尔爵士中校，他是艾尔选区的保守党议员，1919年4月，他曾在阿尔伯特音乐厅观看英国法西斯联盟的集会。是的。那么汤姆，我们的姐妹播客《政治余温》（The Rest is Politics）经常在阿尔伯特音乐厅录制，不是吗？实际上，它们是非常相似的企业。你会喜欢的。嗯，是的，但在我们开始讲关于场地的笑话之前，我们或许应该先看看英国法西斯联盟是否曾在我们出现过的场地出现过。确实如此。那么托马斯·摩尔爵士，我告诉你
this, he was the MP for Air. Having written that, he was the MP for Air until 1964. So he was the MP for Air when the Beatles were visiting the United States. Yeah, but what's even more extraordinary, so the leader of the British Union of Fascists, spoiler alert, was Sir Oswald Mosley. And he was popping up on British chat shows in the 70s. And his wife, Lady Mosley, former Diana Mitford, she was popping up on interviews as well. And as late as 1989, she was the guest on Desert Island Discs, where one of her eight discs was a whiter shade of pale. Oh, no. Do you think she did that deliberately?
这件事，他是艾尔选区的议员。写下这些后，他一直担任艾尔选区的议员直到1964年。所以当披头士乐队访问美国时，他还是艾尔选区的议员。是的，但更令人震惊的是，英国法西斯联盟的领袖——剧透预警——是奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利爵士。他在70年代经常出现在英国的脱口秀节目中。他的妻子莫斯利夫人，即前戴安娜·米特福德，也经常出现在采访中。直到1989年，她还是《荒岛唱片》（Desert Island Discs）的嘉宾，她选择的八张唱片之一是《苍白的浅影》（A Whiter Shade of Pale）。哦，不。你觉得她是故意的吗？
It's a jaw dropping. One of the most shocking radio. I listened to it last night because we will be coming to the Mitford's in due course. We certainly will. Because we're going to be doing four episodes on British fascism. Yeah. So, Dominic, very much your choice. It was my choice.
这简直让人目瞪口呆。这是最令人震惊的广播之一。我昨晚听了，因为我们迟早会讲到米特福德家族。我们肯定会讲的。因为我们将制作四集关于英国法西斯的节目。是的。所以，多米尼克，这完全是你的选择。这是我的选择。
Yeah. Thanks for that. So people can interpret that. You love a, very much your choice. It was my choice. It was my choice. Yeah. Thanks for that. So people can interpret that. You love a British fascist. Anyway, they want. But it's such an interesting topic, isn't it? It is an interesting topic. I mean, we will be talking about the whole sweep of British fascism through to the end
是的。谢谢。所以人们可以这样解读。你喜欢一个，完全是你的选择。这是我的选择。这是我的选择。是的。谢谢。所以人们可以这样解读。你喜欢一个英国法西斯分子。不管怎样，他们想怎么解读都行。但这确实是一个有趣的话题，不是吗？这是一个有趣的话题。我的意思是，我们将讨论英国法西斯主义的整个过程，直到
of the Second World War and with the, in the persona of, you know, Diana Mosley, who you were listening to on Desert Island Dicks, beyond. I mean, she is still saying some quite disturbing things in the 1980s. Hitler was so charming. Oh, God. He had such beautiful hands. She doesn't say that Hitler had beautiful hands, does she? Beautiful hands, the most charming manners.
第二次世界大战结束，以及以你刚才在《荒岛唱片》中听到的戴安娜·莫斯利为代表的人物，甚至更远。我的意思是，她在1980年代仍然在说一些相当令人不安的话。希特勒是如此迷人。哦，天哪。他有那么漂亮的手。她没说希特勒有漂亮的手，对吧？漂亮的手，最迷人的举止。
Oh, no. Oh, God. Right. Well, you've got that to look forward to, Tom's enormous repertoire of Mitford impersonations. Do you know what her luxury item was? Her luxury item? A soft pillow.
哦，不。哦，天哪。好吧，汤姆，你那庞大的米特福德模仿秀值得期待。你知道她的奢侈品是什么吗？她的奢侈品？一个软枕头。
A soft pillow, was that? A soft pillow. It wasn't like a mouser or something. No, it wasn't. It was a soft pillow. That's good. Okay. I mean, that's actually a pretty, that's not a fascist luxury necessarily, I wouldn't have
一个软枕头，是吗？一个软枕头。不是像毛瑟枪之类的东西。不，不是。是一个软枕头。那很好。好吧。我的意思是，这实际上是一个相当，我不认为那一定是法西斯式的奢侈品。
said. Very useful for killing princes at the tower. Oh, very good. Right. Now, some listeners may think British fascism, oxymoron, because fascism could never have worked in Britain. And I think people who believe that would say, oh, British people have an inherent love of liberty, a reverence of parliamentary democracy. They have a distrust of uniforms, going back to the long standing distrust of standing armies in Britain. And of course, the famous sense of humor, which means that we would always laugh at paramilitaries and authoritarian groups. And I think, I'm sure you'd agree with me, Tom, that that's rubbish, don't you? Do you think that's rubbish? So the definitive book on this is Harar for the Black Shirts by Martin Pugh.
非常有用于在塔中杀死王子。哦，非常好。好了。现在，一些听众可能会认为“英国法西斯主义”是一个矛盾修辞，因为法西斯主义在英国永远行不通。我认为相信这一点的人会说，哦，英国人天生热爱自由，崇尚议会民主。他们对制服有一种不信任感，这可以追溯到英国长期以来对常备军的不信任。当然，还有著名的幽默感，这意味着我们总是会嘲笑准军事组织和威权团体。我想，汤姆，你肯定会同意我的观点，那都是胡说八道，对吧？你觉得那是胡说八道吗？关于这个问题的权威著作是马丁·普的《为黑衫军欢呼》（Hurrah for the Black Shirts）。
And Harar for the Black Shirts was obviously a notorious headline in the Daily Mail, which did back the black shirts for what, a six month period, a year? I can't remember. Yeah. And he makes the case that fascism was much more of a threat to Britain than most people have thought. I wasn't entirely convinced by it, I have to say. I do think that British parliamentary democracy, it may not be that
《为黑衫军欢呼》显然是《每日邮报》的一个臭名昭著的头条新闻，该报确实支持过黑衫军，支持了多久？六个月，一年？我不记得了。是的。他提出的观点是，法西斯主义对英国的威胁比大多数人想象的要大得多。我必须说，我并没有完全被说服。我确实认为英国的议会民主，可能并不是因为
people in Britain have a kind of inherent devotion to parliamentary democracy, but I think the frameworks of it, the way that it is very hard for people in the first past the post system for kind of radical fringes to seize control of the commanding heights. I do think that it made it exceedingly unlikely that fascists would ever come to power in Britain. I think it's unlikely that it would come to power, but I don't think fascism is inherently un-British. Because actually, some of the roots of fascism that we talked about, for example, in our podcast about the rise of the Nazis, were British. I mean, one of the authors that Hitler most admired, Houston Stuart Chamberlain, was British and was writing in part,
英国人天生就对议会民主有某种忠诚，但我认为它的框架，即在“领先者当选”制度下，激进边缘派很难夺取权力高地。我确实认为这使得法西斯分子在英国掌权的可能性极低。我认为它掌权的可能性很小，但我不认为法西斯主义本质上是不符合英国国情的。因为实际上，我们之前在关于纳粹崛起的播客中谈到的法西斯主义的一些根源，其实是英国的。我的意思是，希特勒最崇拜的作者之一，休斯顿·斯图尔特·张伯伦，就是英国人，而且他在写作时，
his anti-Semitism was driven in part by his hatred of Benjamin Disraeli and the liberals. And the fact that Disraeli was Jewish? Of course. A rootless cosmopolitan? Was that the kind of part of the vibe? Exactly. Exactly. I think that is part of the vibe, as you put it.
他的反犹太主义在一定程度上是由他对本杰明·迪斯雷利和自由派的仇恨所驱动的。而迪斯雷利是犹太人这一事实？当然。一个无根的国际主义者？那是那种氛围的一部分吗？正是如此。正是如此。我认为正如你所说，那是氛围的一部分。
But also, I think a lot of those ingredients that we talked about in the Nazis episode one that we did earlier in the year, they were there in Britain in the late Victorian Edwardian period in just as pronounced, although slightly different ways, to how they were in Germany. I mean, so many of the elements of fascism in Germany and Italy are present in Britain. So fascism as a generational revolt against the old, fascism as an expression of contempt for the failures of parliamentary democracy, fascism as a reaction to the First World War. There are a couple of elements in Britain that I think are distinctive.
但同时，我认为我们在今年早些时候做的纳粹第一集播客中谈到的许多因素，在维多利亚时代晚期和爱德华时代的英国也同样明显，尽管方式与德国略有不同。我的意思是，德国和意大利法西斯主义的许多要素在英国都存在。比如，法西斯主义作为对旧时代的一代人的反叛，法西斯主义作为对议会民主失败的蔑视的表达，法西斯主义作为对第一次世界大战的反应。我认为英国有两个独特的要素。
So one is that British fascism very, very strongly emphasises women. And that's something that we'll come to when we do the podcast about the Mitfords, because of course they're so prominent in the movement and in the popular memory of the movement. I think the other fascinating thing about Britain specifically is the way in which British fascism could have been perceived at various points as being, this will sound so weird to many listeners, as being progressive, as being anti-capitalist, as appealing to people who
一个是英国法西斯主义非常、非常强烈地强调女性。当我们做关于米特福德家族的播客时，我们会谈到这一点，因为她们在运动中以及在对该运动的集体记忆中都非常突出。我认为英国特别令人着迷的另一点是，英国法西斯主义在某些时候可能被视为——这对许多听众来说听起来会很奇怪——进步的、反资本主义的，能够吸引那些
would otherwise have voted Labour. Of course, Oswald Mosley comes to fascism from the Labour Party. Yes. I mean, you slightly see that in the way that the far right in Europe at the moment, so Marine Le Pen I guess would be the obvious example, who has... I know that she has repudiated much that her father represented, but obviously comes from that French fascist tradition. Those are the wellsprings of her party, but at the same time is clearly appealing to people on the left. So there is absolutely that strand. But another strand
本来会投票给工党的人。当然，奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利是从工党转向法西斯主义的。是的。我的意思是，你从目前欧洲极右翼的表现中也能稍微看到这一点，比如玛丽娜·勒庞可能就是一个明显的例子，她……我知道她已经否认了她父亲所代表的许多东西，但显然她来自那个法国法西斯传统。那些是她政党的源头，但同时显然也在吸引左翼人士。所以绝对存在这一派。但另一派
within British fascism, and it's definitely there in German fascism as well, but I think it's particularly strong in British fascism, is environmentalism. A concern with, I suppose, the blood, but also the soil of Britain. It's wildlife, it's trees, a sense that there should properly be a communion with the very essence of the natural world. And that's also, I think, a bit unsettling. You were reminding me that that much-loved children's book, Tarka the Otter, one of those classic sort of fictions of the English countryside for children, the author of that, Henry Williamson,
在英国法西斯主义内部，在德国法西斯主义中也绝对存在，但我认为在英国法西斯主义中尤为强烈，那就是环保主义。一种对，我想是血缘，但也对英国土地的关注。它的野生动物，它的树木，一种认为应该与自然世界的本质进行真正交流的感觉。而且我认为，这也有点令人不安。你提醒我，那本备受喜爱的儿童读物《塔卡水獭》（Tarka the Otter），那种经典的英国乡村儿童小说之一，其作者亨利·威廉姆森，
who had fought in the First World War, he, of course, flirted with fascism, didn't he? He did. Yes, absolutely. He did. Yeah. So let's talk a little bit about what I mean about the roots of fascism. So as you say, Martin Pugh in his book, Hurrah for the Black Shirts, he lists a whole series of things that have analogues in Germany that in Germany look like really important ingredients of the rise
他曾参加过第一次世界大战，他当然也曾涉足法西斯主义，不是吗？他确实涉足过。是的，绝对是。他确实涉足过。是的。那么让我们谈谈我所说的法西斯主义根源。正如你所说，马丁·普在他的书《为黑衫军欢呼》中，列举了一系列在德国有类似物的东西，在德国，这些看起来像是纳粹崛起中非常重要的因素。
of Nazism. Of course, in Britain, they don't lead quite to the same place, so we don't notice them so much. So we've forgotten about them. So we forget, for example, that Britain before the First World War was in many ways not a very democratic country, that only six out of 10 men could vote and no women at all could vote. So in other words, the idea that there's this inbuilt reverence for democracy, I don't think quite stands up. That Britain, like Germany, has this deep sense of kind of medieval nostalgia. This looking back to the vanished past, particularly the Middle Ages, Arthurian fantasies, all of those things that were floating around in Hitler's imagination, they are floating around in
当然，在英国，它们并没有导致同样的结果，所以我们没有那么注意到它们。所以我们忘记了它们。例如，我们忘记了第一次世界大战前的英国在许多方面并不是一个非常民主的国家，只有十分之六的男性有投票权，而女性根本没有投票权。所以换句话说，那种认为英国人天生崇敬民主的观点，我认为并不完全站得住脚。英国和德国一样，有一种深刻的、中世纪怀旧感。这种回顾消失的过去，特别是中世纪、亚瑟王幻想，所有这些在希特勒想象中漂浮的东西，也在
the imagination of loads of people in Britain. The most obvious example who we've done a podcast about who is not by any means a fascist and hates fascism is J.R.R. Tolkien. So in his backward lookingness, he's actually anti-capitalist, isn't he? He doesn't like development. He loves the countryside. He hates the modern world. He's not an enormous fan of modern mass democracy. So this is one of the things that also, it does seem to me, a fascist dog that doesn't bark in the night is that Tolkien is very into the idea of sacred monarchy, swords, holy swords, all this kind of thing, that with just a nudge of the gearstick could come to seem fascist because Himmler, of course, is obsessed with all this stuff, all this Arthurian mythology, the Wagnerian things. But Britain, which is the home of
英国许多人的想象中漂浮。我们做过播客的最明显的例子，他绝不是法西斯主义者，而且憎恨法西斯主义，那就是J.R.R.托尔金。所以在他那种向后看的态度中，他实际上是反资本主义的，不是吗？他不喜欢发展。他热爱乡村。他憎恨现代世界。他不是现代大众民主的忠实粉丝。所以这也是其中之一，在我看来，法西斯主义中那只“在夜里不叫的狗”是，托尔金非常沉迷于神圣君主制、剑、圣剑等这类想法，只要稍微推动一下齿轮，就可能看起来像法西斯主义，因为希姆莱当然痴迷于所有这些东西，所有这些亚瑟王神话、瓦格纳式的东西。但英国，作为
King Arthur, actually never really seems to have taken a fascist form, that obsession with Arthurian myth. But there were good reasons for that, Tom. I mean, I don't want to jump ahead too much, but I think there are two very obvious reasons why that dog doesn't bark. And they are contingent. They are that Britain doesn't lose the First World War. Of course, we'll be coming to that. And that the Great Depression is nowhere near as intense in Britain as it is in most other Western countries. And perhaps that it already has a monarchy as well. Maybe. So there's something we talked about with the rise of the Nazis was the fascination with hygiene or with race. I mean, that is absolutely present in Britain. If you look at periodicals
亚瑟王的故乡，实际上从未真正采取过法西斯形式，那种对亚瑟王神话的痴迷。但汤姆，这有很好的理由。我的意思是，我不想跳得太快，但我认为那只狗不叫有两个非常明显的原因。它们是偶然的。它们是英国没有输掉第一次世界大战。当然，我们会讲到这一点。而且大萧条在英国远没有在大多数其他西方国家那么严重。也许是因为它已经有一个君主制了。也许吧。所以我们谈到纳粹崛起时，谈到过对卫生或种族的痴迷。我的意思是，这在英国绝对存在。如果你看期刊
and books from the 1890s and 1900s, they're full of stuff about racial rejuvenation, degeneracy. We've lost a sense of organic national unity, cosmopolitan liberalism has undermined the virility of the race. I mean, that guy used the word virility, didn't he, describing the meeting in the Albert Hall, absolute obsession with that. And that links to the other element, which is antisemitism. There was quite a lot of antisemitism in Britain before the First World War. We'll come onto this later when we talk about the Battle of Cable Street in the East End, the confrontation between fascists and anti-fascists in the 1930s. But if you open a book by Hilaire Belloc or G.K. Chesterton, written in the 1900s, there's loads of stuff there about the cosmopolitan Jews, about Jews in Russia.
和1890年代及1900年代的书籍，它们充满了关于种族复兴、退化的内容。我们失去了有机民族团结的感觉，世界主义的自由主义破坏了种族的活力。我的意思是，那个家伙用了“活力”这个词，不是吗，描述在阿尔伯特音乐厅的会议，绝对是对那点的痴迷。这与另一个要素有关，即反犹太主义。第一次世界大战前，英国存在相当多的反犹太主义。当我们谈到1930年代东区的电缆街之战（Battle of Cable Street），即法西斯分子与反法西斯分子之间的对抗时，我们会讲到这一点。但如果你打开希莱尔·贝洛克或G.K.切斯特顿在1900年代写的书，里面有很多关于世界主义犹太人、关于俄罗斯犹太人的内容。
So Chesterton, a Catholicolic apologist is i think strikingly anti-semitic but at the same time he is very strong against eugenics which yeah most people in britain are george bernard shaw famously obsessed by yes and so mary stopes who becomes uh one of the kind of the groundbreaking leading figures in favor of that i mean she becomes a big fan of Hitler. She's sending him volumes of terrible poetry and all kinds of things. Well, maybe you should read out some of, when you do the Mitfords, you could read out some of Mary Stokes' poetry. We love a bad poem on the rest of history.
所以切斯特顿，一位天主教辩护士，我认为他非常反犹太，但同时他非常反对优生学，这在英国大多数人中是……乔治·萧伯纳以痴迷于此而闻名，是的，玛丽·斯托普斯也是，她成为了支持这一点的开创性领袖人物之一，我的意思是，她成为了希特勒的忠实粉丝。她给他寄去了一卷卷糟糕的诗歌和各种各样的东西。好吧，也许你应该读一些，当你做米特福德家族时，你可以读一些玛丽·斯托普斯的诗。我们喜欢《历史余温》里的烂诗。
We do, we do. So there's a general culture of all this kind of stuff. Actually, John Carey, great literary critic in his book, The Intellectuals and the Matters, which was basically a massive dissection of the Bloomsbury group and their kind of predecessors. The most Sandbrook book not written by Dominic Sandbrook ever written. He's very good on the ways in which their kind of cultural imagination feels very proto-fascist. I mean, that doesn't necessarily, of course, mean they are fascists, but it just means that fascism, the ideas of fascism are not as alien and unfamiliar and unsettling as people might think. Well, the cooking ingredients are
我们喜欢，我们喜欢。所以有一种关于所有这些东西的普遍文化。实际上，伟大的文学评论家约翰·凯里在他的书《知识分子与大众》（The Intellectuals and the Masses）中，基本上是对布卢姆茨伯里派及其前身进行了大规模的剖析。这是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克没写过的最像桑德布鲁克的书。他非常擅长分析他们的文化想象力感觉非常像原始法西斯主义的方式。我的意思是，这当然不一定意味着他们是法西斯主义者，但这只是意味着法西斯主义、法西斯主义的思想并不像人们想象的那么陌生、不熟悉和令人不安。好吧，烹饪原料是
there, but you still need people to make the meal. You do, exactly. Well, you need the right circumstances. And actually all of this is turbocharged by war, not the Great War actually, but the Boer War. So this is the really interesting thing, that actually all of these things get a massive boost from Britain's poor performance at the beginning of the Boer War, 1890-1902. There's a particular week where the British lose three battles to the Boers called the Black Week. And after that, there's this massive upsurge of columns and sort of self-flagellating diatribes about national degeneracy. That basically, we have become an industrialized urban people, and we have lost our national
有的，但你仍然需要人来做这顿饭。确实，没错。好吧，你需要合适的条件。实际上，所有这一切都被战争涡轮增压了，不是第一次世界大战，而是布尔战争。所以这是真正有趣的事情，实际上所有这些东西都从英国在布尔战争（1890-1902）初期的糟糕表现中得到了巨大的推动。有一个特定的星期，英国人输给了布尔人三场战役，被称为“黑色星期”。在那之后，出现了大规模的专栏文章和关于民族退化的自我鞭笞式的抨击。基本上，我们已经变成了一个工业化的城市民族，我们已经失去了我们的民族
spirit, our virility, and we need this new spirit. And there's this huge cult in the early 1900s of what's called national efficiency. So basically, loads of politicians sign up to it. There's a National Service League set up under Lord Roberts, sponsored by Roger Kipling, that has 100,000 members that are calling for national service, compulsory national service, so that young men, all these deracinated, pallid young men of the cities, will be turned into fighting men for Britain. And obviously, the most famous example, Tom, is the Boy Scouts. So the Boy Scouts
精神，我们的活力，我们需要这种新精神。在1900年代初期，有一种被称为“国家效率”的巨大崇拜。所以基本上，许多政客都签署了它。在罗伯茨勋爵领导下成立了一个国家服务联盟，由鲁德亚德·吉卜林赞助，拥有10万名成员，呼吁实行国民服役，强制性的国民服役，这样年轻人，所有这些城市里无根的、苍白的年轻人，就会变成英国的战斗人员。显然，最著名的例子，汤姆，是童子军。所以童子军
set up 1908. It's inspired by the Mafeking Cadet Corps that Sir Robert Baden-Powell had seen in the Boer War. And so this, I think that, oh,
成立于1908年。它的灵感来自于罗伯特·贝登堡爵士在布尔战争中看到的马弗京学员团。所以这个，我认为，哦，
British people don't like people marching around in uniforms. I mean, it's nonsense. There are lots of people marching around in uniforms in the 1900s.
英国人不喜欢人们穿着制服到处走。我的意思是，这是胡说八道。在1900年代，有很多人穿着制服到处走。
We talked about this in our episodes on the build-up to the First World War in the context of our Irish episodes. Yes, exactly. Kind of paramilitary bodies in Ireland and starting to cross to Great Britain. Yeah, they were absolutely. The rifle clubs, the Ulster volunteers, as Dan Jackson was telling us
我们在关于第一次世界大战前夕的剧集中，在我们的爱尔兰剧集的背景下谈到了这一点。是的，没错。爱尔兰的准军事组织，并开始跨越到大不列颠。是的，他们绝对是。步枪俱乐部，阿尔斯特志愿者，正如丹·杰克逊在我们的爱尔兰剧集之一中告诉我们的那样，在利物浦、格拉斯哥、纽卡斯尔等地都有志愿者，他们说如果自治被强加给阿尔斯特各郡，那么他们就有理由拿起武器对抗他们所认为的非法的自由党政府。多米尼克，体育在其中的作用是什么，男子气概的崇拜，拳击？这绝对是其中的一部分，对我来说，考虑到英国法西斯分子糟糕的选举表现，这个主题打开了通往20世纪初英国的窗口，这非常迷人，但它也有很多我们已经在《历史余温》中涵盖的其他主题的联系，所以我当时在想《所罗门王的宝藏》（King Solomon's Mines），H·莱德·哈格德
in one of our Irish episodes, there are volunteers in places like Liverpool, Glasgow, Newcastle, and so on, who say that if home rule is forced upon the counties of Ulster, then they will be justified in taking up arms against what they see as an illegitimate liberal government. And Dominic, what is the role of sport in this, the cult of manliness, boxing? It's absolutely part of it, that um to me british fascism given the abysmal electoral performance of british fascists it's fascinating how much this subject has opened up this window into early 20th century britain but it's also that there are so many links with other subjects that we've covered on the rest is history so i was thinking about king solomon's minds h rider
和帝国小说，以及这种对男子气概、证明自己的痴迷。显然，体育完全反映了这一点，不是吗？这个想法，我的意思是，体育被构想出来，有组织的体育被构想出来，是为了让工厂和城市的工人们走出来，呼吸新鲜空气，再次成为充满活力的年轻人，所有这些东西。我的意思是，这不一定是不祥的。我的意思是，人们今天仍然在为此争论。认为参与体育运动必然会导致法西斯主义的想法。
haggard and the fiction of empire and this obsession with manliness, with proving yourself. And obviously, sports completely reflects that, doesn't it? The idea that, I mean, sport is conceived, organized sport is conceived to get the workers of the factories and the cities out and breathing the fresh air and being virile young men again, all that sort of stuff. I mean, that's not necessarily sinister. I mean, people are still arguing for that today. The idea that participation in sport is necessarily going to lead to fascism.
同意。就像，汤姆，我完全同意你的观点。就像热爱乡村、不喜欢城市、当童子军一样，所有这些事情本身一点也不邪恶，我的意思是它们非常合理，你知道，你可能不一定同意它们，你可能不想当童子军，你可能热爱城市，但持有这些观点并不意味着你是，你知道，你并没有走在通往奥斯威辛的路上，或者类似的事情。但正如你所说，周围有很多有趣的成分。所以认为你的敌人、你的政治对手是非法的、颠覆性的、是内部敌人的一部分的想法。提醒一下听过爱尔兰剧集的听众，1912年，保守党领袖
Agreed. Just like, Tom, I completely agree with you. Just like loving the countryside, disliking cities, being a Boy Scout, all of these other things, none of them are in themselves at all sinister i mean they're perfectly reasonable you know you might not agree with them necessarily you might not want to be a boy scout you might love cities but to have those views is not a sign that you are you know you're not on the road that leads to auschwitz or something but as you said there are lots of interesting ingredients around so the idea that your enemies, your political opponents are illegitimate, are subversive, are part of an enemy within. Just to remind people who listen to the Ireland episodes, in 1912, the leader of the Conservatives,
安德鲁·博纳·劳将自由党政府描述为一个通过欺诈手段夺取专制权力的革命委员会。他说，在给予爱尔兰自治权时，他们正在摧毁英国宪法。人们将有理由做任何事情来反抗他们，包括使用武力。所以换句话说，在不同的情况下，这可能是一个在两次世界大战期间会产生非常血腥后果的故事的开始。当然，它没有，或者没有它可能产生的那么血腥，因为英国赢得了第一次世界大战。但在不同的情况下，我认为会有非常不同的结果。你不觉得成分都在那里吗？
Andrew Bonallor, described the Liberal government as a revolutionary committee which is seized by fraud upon despotic power. And he says, in giving home rule to Ireland, they are destroying the British constitution. People will be justified in doing home rule to Ireland, they are destroying the British constitution. People will be justified in doing anything to resist them, including force. So in other words, that could be, in different circumstances, the beginning of a story that would have very bloody consequences in the interwar years. Of course, it doesn't, or not as bloody as it could have been, because Britain wins the First World War. But in different circumstances, I think there would have been a very different kind of outcome. Don't you think the ingredients are there?
我同意。我们绝对同意，在第一次世界大战中的失败是德国发生的事情的前提。所以反过来，你可以说英国没有在第一次世界大战中被击败，意味着这些成分在很大程度上只是保持为成分。在我们谈到第一次世界大战及其后果之前，有一个关于英国人对外国人态度的疑问。所以显然，英国统治着一个庞大的帝国，而英国统治的理由，特别是对非白人人口的统治，通常是用公开的种族主义术语来表达的。所以这大概是混合的一部分。而且当人们谈论退化时，在30年代，他们谈论的是犹太人。大体上是犹太人被指责为结构内部的退化因素。他们
I do. We've absolutely agreed that it's defeat in the First World War that is the precondition for what happens in Germany. And so conversely, you could argue the fact that Britain isn't defeated in the First World War mean that these ingredients, by large just remain the ingredients. Just before we come to the First World War and its aftermath, a question about British attitudes to foreigners. So obviously, Britain is ruling an enormous empire, and the justification for British rule, particularly of non-white populations, is often couched in overtly racist terms. So that presumably is a part of the mix. And also when people talk about degeneracy, in the 30s, what they're talking about there are Jews. It's Jews by and large who are being accused of a degenerate element within the fabric. They're
被视为杆菌，被视为德国政治体内的有害微生物。在此之前，英国有类似的情况吗？是的。我的意思是，我们稍后会在第三集中谈到东区的电缆街之战时讲到这一点。但是的，你是绝对正确的。1904年或1905年左右通过了一项《外国人法》，我不记得确切日期了，试图限制逃离俄罗斯帝国大屠杀的东欧犹太人的移民。它是非常局部化的。所以在大伦敦，特别是在利兹、曼彻斯特，
seen as bacilli, as noxious microbes within the body politic of Germany. Is there anything of that going on in Britain beforehand? Yes. I mean, we'll come to this later on in episode three when we talk about Battle of Cable Street in the East End. But yes, you're absolutely right. There is an Aliens Act passed in, I think, 1904, 1905. I can't remember the exact date, to try and limit the immigration of Eastern European Jews who are fleeing the pogroms in the Russian Empire. It's very localized. So in London, particularly in Leeds, in Manchester,
大量东欧犹太人定居的地方，难民定居的地方，有人试图煽动它。有人在抱怨。你知道，所有那些如此熟悉的语言，人们谈论暴民和蜂群，并使用，正如你所说，所有那些关于杆菌的医学化语言和所有那些东西。所以那是如此熟悉。人们谈论暴民和蜂群，并使用，正如你所说，所有那些关于杆菌的医学化语言和所有那些东西。所以这一切都在那里。它不是全国性的，因为大多数地方没有受到这场辩论的影响，但它绝对存在于
the places where large numbers of Eastern European Jews settle, refugees where they settle, there are people trying to stir it up. There are people complaining. You know, all the language that is so familiar, people talking about mobs and swarms and using, as you say, all that medicalized language about Basile and all that stuff. So that is so familiar. People talking about mobs and swarms and using, as you say, all that medicalized language about bacilli and all that stuff. So that is all there. It's not nationwide because most places are untouched by this debate, but it is absolutely there in the
国民对话中。所以是的。在第一次世界大战前夕，还有一种对外国间谍的焦虑，不是吗？所以马丁·普的《为黑衫军欢呼》中有一句非常有趣的台词，实际上也是关于《每日邮报》的。报业大亨阿尔弗雷德·哈姆斯沃思邀请《每日邮报》的读者报告可疑外国人的踪迹
kind of national conversation. So yes. There's also, in the buildup to the First World War, there's an anxiety about foreign spies, isn't there? So there's a very funny line in Martin Pugh's Hurrah for the Black Shirts, again, actually about the Daily Mail. The press magnate Alfred Harmsworth invited readers of the Daily Mail to report sightings of suspicious foreigners
并宣传可能的入侵路线，这些路线总是经过那些需要提高《邮报》发行量的城镇。好吧，我的意思是，我们之前谈过那个。所以那是关于，我不记得他怎么发音他的名字了。我想是威廉·勒·奎。他是那个专门研究入侵文学的家伙。他的书，正如你所说，在《邮报》上连载，它们在预测德国
and advertised likely invasion routes, which invariably passed through towns where the mail circulation required a boost. Well, I mean, we've talked about that before. So that's about, I can't remember how he pronounced his name. I think it's William Le Quex. He was this guy who specialized in invasion literature. And his books, as you say, were serialized in the mail and they were predicting German
入侵之类的东西。它在多尔金被阻止了。正是如此。当然，你知道为了增加发行量，为了让人们兴奋，那些有德国战役和类似事情的地方，都是读者很多的地方，因为显然他们会，你知道，瑟比顿正受到德国军队的攻击，但是的，有这种，我认为有对外部敌人的恐惧和对内部敌人的恐惧，而对内部敌人的恐惧，你是绝对正确的，这是一只“不叫的狗”。
invasions and stuff. It was being stopped at Dorking. Exactly. Of course, you you know to increase circulation to get people excited the places that were german battles and things were places where there'd be lots of readers because obviously they would they would you know surbiton is under attack from german forces but yes there's this sort of i think there's the fear of enemies without and enemies within and the enemies within fear you're absolutely right that this is a dog that doesn't bark.
而且我认为很大程度上是因为英国赢得了第一次世界大战。但我认为值得注意的是，尽管英国赢得了第一次世界大战，但这只狗并没有消失。所以第一次世界大战期间，有很多关于内部敌人的东西，但现在主要是德国人，不是吗？这就是为什么萨克森-科堡家族改名为温莎家族的原因，例如。但不仅仅是德国人。它是德国人，特别是在战争快结束时，它变成了人们所认为的德国人、犹太人、布尔什维克（显然是在俄国革命之后）以及某种同路人的邪恶联系。
And I think largely because Britain wins the First World War. But I think it's remarkable how even though Britain wins the First World War, the dog doesn't go away. So during the First World War, there was loads of stuff about enemies within. But now it's chiefly Germans, isn't it? This is why the House of Saxe-Coburg changes its name to the House of Windsor, for instance. But it's not just Germans. It's German, especially towards the end of the war, it becomes what people see as this unholy nexus of Germans, Jews, Bolsheviks, obviously after the Russian Revolution, and sort of fellow travellers.
我不一定想说英国左翼，因为那听起来像是在谈论工党内部的人。有一个著名的东西叫“黑皮书”，是由一个叫哈罗德·斯宾塞的家伙编写的，他是一个被军事情报部门开除的反犹太主义者，他在1917年编写了这本书，这是一份47,000人的名单，那是一个很大的数字，包括内阁大臣、内阁大臣的妻子、高级自由党政客等等。它说这些人都是，这是他们使用的词，这些人都是变态，他们被德国人勒索了，或者他们正在与德国人合作。
I don't necessarily want to say the British left, because that makes it sound like you're talking about people within the Labour Party. there's a famous thing called the black book that is compiled by a guy called harold spencer who's an anti-semite who's been thrown out of army intelligence and he compiles this book in 1917 which is a list of 47 000 people that's a lot of including cabinet ministers cabinet ministers wives senior liberal politicians and so on. And it says these people are all, and this is the word they use, these people are all perverts and they have been blackmailed by the Germans or they're working with the Germans.
而且有一个巨大的阴谋。德国人参与其中。全世界的犹太人参与其中。布尔什维克参与其中。所以1917年之后，这种焦虑一定被涡轮增压了。绝对被涡轮增压了。它通常被归咎于犹太人，不是吗？哦，是的。
And there's this huge conspiracy. Germans are in it. The worldwide jury is in it. The Bolsheviks are in it. So after 1917, that anxiety must get turbocharged. Absolutely turbocharged. It's often blamed on the Jews, isn't it? Oh, yes.
俄国革命被英国的保守党人归咎于犹太人。绝对是这样。是的，所以我认为一件迷人的事情是，在1920年代初期，顺便说一句，这个故事的很大一部分将是关于20年代的。如果你脑子里有一个关于咆哮的20年代、鸡尾酒吧、《了不起的盖茨比》所有这些东西的想法，把它放在一边，那不是《了不起的盖茨比》所有这些东西，把它放在一边。那在英国根本不是事实。英国是一个非常、非常分裂、不快乐、
The Russian Revolution by conservatives in Britain. Absolutely, it is. Yeah, so I think a fascinating thing is how in the early 1920s, by the way, so much of this story is going to be about the 20s. If you've got an idea in your head about the roaring 20s, cocktail bars, Great Gatsby, all that stuff, put it aside, that is not Great Gatsby, all that stuff, put it aside. That is not the case in Britain at all. Britain is a very, very divided, unhappy,
在20年代伤痕累累的地方，失业率很高，经济悲惨，政治一团糟。中产阶级对税收非常不满。所以你刚才提到了阿尔弗雷德·哈姆斯沃思。所以他的兄弟，罗瑟米尔勋爵，在1920年代成立了“反浪费联盟”，这是一个很好的例子，说明英国政治右翼的许多人认为保守党通过与劳合·乔治勾结而背叛了。他们都是这种议会阴谋的一部分，旨在贬低货币和掠夺中产阶级。为了向人们解释这一点，劳合·乔治，自由党战时首相，
war-scarred place in the 20s, very high unemployment, the economy miserable, politics in a complete and utter mess. The middle classes are very upset about taxes. So you mentioned Alfred Harmsworth earlier on. So his brother, Lord Rothermere, he sets up the Anti-Waste League in the 1920s, which is a really good example of how a lot of people on the right of British politics think that the Conservatives have sold out by getting into bed with Lloyd George. They're all part of this kind of parliamentary conspiracy to debauch the currency and fleece the middle classes. Just to explain that for people, Lloyd George, liberal war prime minister,
然后在战后，基本上与保守党勾结，作为保持自己权力的一种方式。是的，还有出售贵族头衔。所以这是另一件激怒人们的事情。他们说，这些人实际上，这些骗子基本上是在把贵族头衔、上议院的席位卖给他们的富人朋友，而我们却被税收负担压得喘不过气来。罢工率飙升，确实如此。所以1919年、1920年的罢工大幅增加，这当然进一步助长了中产阶级、某种小C保守派对布尔什维克主义的恐惧。所有这一切都嵌入了英国的想象中，并集中在犹太人的想法上
and then after the war, basically gets into bed with the conservatives as a way of keeping himself in power. Yes, and selling peerages. So that's another thing that inflames people. They say, these people are actually, these crooks are basically flogging off peerages, places in the House of Lords, to their rich friends, while we are crippled with the burden of taxes. Strikes have gone through the roof, which they have. So a massive increase in strikes in 1919, 1920, which of course further fuels middle class, sort of small C conservative fears of Bolshevism. And all of this becomes embedded in the British imagination and focused on the idea of a Jewish
阴谋。所以1920年、1921年，《泰晤士报》等报纸的版面上充满了报道，特别是关于《锡安长老会纪要》（Protocols of the Elders of Zion），正如你所知，汤姆，这是一种种族主义、反犹太主义的幻想，已经漂浮了15、20年左右。我的意思是，人们在凡尔赛和会上交换《锡安长老会纪要》的副本。但到20年代，它被广泛认为是伪造的？它被认为是伪造的。所以1921年，《泰晤士报》刊登了三篇文章说《锡安长老会纪要》是伪造的。但通过给它这么多曝光时间，他们助长了这样一种想法，即存在一种涉及美国金融家的阴谋。
conspiracy. So in 1920, 1921, the pages of newspapers like the Times are full of reports, particularly about the Protocols of the Elders of Zion, which, as you will know, Tom, is a kind of a racist, anti-Semitic fantasy that has been floating around for 15, 20 years or so. I mean, people were swapping copies of the Protocols of the Elders of Zion at their Versailles Peace Conference. But which is broadly accepted to be a fake by the 20s? It is accepted to be a fake. So in 1921, the Times runs three articles to say the Protocols of the Elders of Zion is a fake. But by giving it so much airtime, they fuel this idea that there is this sort of conspiracy that takes in American financiers.
共产主义者。共产主义者，某种自由派政客，工会激进分子，住在肮脏寄宿公寓里的犹太人。我告诉你谁对此非常热衷。是的。是约翰·巴肯。我正要说约翰·巴肯。《三十九级台阶》（The 39 Steps）和《绿斗篷》（Green Mantle）的作者，你知道，惊险的间谍故事。但这种认为在所有正在发生的邪恶事情背后都有某种犹太金融家的想法，以及同时美国财阀和苏联布尔什维克在勾结反对
Communists. Communists, sort of liberal politicians, trade union militants, Jews in grimy boarding houses. I'll tell you who's all over this. Yeah. It's John Buckham. I was about to say John Buckham. Author of The 39 Steps and Green Mantle and, you know, thrilling spy stories. But this idea that there are kind of Jewish financiers behind everything evil that's happening and that simultaneously American plutocrats and Soviet Bolsheviks are in cahoots against
大英帝国的想法。我的意思是，这是驱动他惊悚小说的动机。确实如此。而且不仅仅是约翰·巴肯，汤姆，阿加莎·克里斯蒂。读一本1920年代的阿加莎·克里斯蒂。里面有很多关于犹太金融家的引用，关于那种控制斯托克波特罢工的傀儡大师，还有在新成立的苏联发生的事情，即与华尔街有联系。我的意思是，所有这些，所有这些偏执的幻想。所以当这种情况发生时，还有另一个因素，你在发给我的笔记中列出了
the British Empire. I mean, it's the motivating idea that powers his thrillers. It is. And not just John Buck and Tom, Agatha Christie. Read an Agatha Christie from the 1920s. And there's lots of references to Jewish financiers, to the sort of puppet masters who are controlling strikes in Stockport, but also stuff going on in the newly established Soviet Union, that there's links to Wall Street. I mean, all of this sort of, all these paranoid fantasies. So while that's happening, there is one other factor that you list in the notes that
这个。对女性选民、摩登女郎、女同性恋者的恐惧。马丁·普列出了一些20年代《邮报》的精彩标题。到处都是男性过剩。为什么社会主义者想要摩登女郎的选票。停止摩登女郎投票的愚蠢行为。是的。所以我想这也是另一部分。这绝对是其中的一部分。顺便说一句，你引用了《每日邮报》，我的意思是，你可以引用1920年代初的任何报纸。《每日快报》。《每日快报》说，英国到处都是留短发、
you sent me for this. Fears of women voters, flappers, lesbians. And Martin Pugh lists some excellent headlines from the mail in the 20s. Men outnumbered everywhere. Why socialists want votes for flappers. Stop the flapper vote folly. Yes. So that's another part as well, I guess. It's absolutely part. And by the way, you quoted in the Daily Mail, I mean, you could have quoted any number of newspapers from the early 1920s. So the Daily Express. The Daily Express says, Britain is full of women with short hair,
裙子不长于苏格兰短裙、臀部狭窄、乳房不明显的女性。这种向更中性类型的转变只能以牺牲女性性器官的完整性为代价来实现。所以这种奇怪的事情，人们心中认为女性获得投票权
skirts no longer than kilts, narrow hips and insignificant breasts. This change to a more neutral type can only be accomplished at the expense of the integrity of a woman's sexual organs. So this sort of weird thing where there's a link in people's minds between women having been given the vote
与摩登女郎的出现、摩登女郎式的时尚之间存在联系，并且有一种女同性恋的浪潮正在席卷英国，在所有这些阴谋论者的脑海深处，他们认为这在某种程度上与伟大的布尔什维克犹太阴谋有关，并与1920年代困扰英国政治的高税收、罢工等事情有关。继续，汤姆。是的。人们会想到F.A.麦基斯顿议员和他对女同性恋者的看法，她们是一种能够削弱文明中最高尚和最美好事物的邪恶。所以他不会受到骄傲游行的欢迎。
and the advent of flappers, flapper kind of fashion, and that there's this sort of tide of lesbianism that is sweeping through Britain that is somehow, at the back of all these kind of conspiracy theorist minds, they think this is somehow connected with the great Bolshevik Jewish conspiracy and with the high taxes, the strikes and things that are afflicting British politics in the 1920s. Go on, Tom. Yeah. One thinks of F.A. Mackiston MP and his view on lesbians, they are an evil which is capable of sapping the highest and the best in civilization. So he wouldn't be welcome on Pride March.
他肯定不会。你引用了托马斯·摩尔爵士中校。还有另一位叫摩尔·布拉巴松的保守党议员，也是中校。那里，最后一个是死刑，所以1920年代流传着很多非常尖锐的观点。好吧，然后在1922年，当人们看向国外时，他们突然看到了一个角色的出现，我认为他将是英国法西斯运动最大的灵感来源，我们会在休息后找出那是谁，汤姆。到时候见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
He certainly wouldn't. You quoted Lieutenant Colonel Sir Thomas Moore. There's another Tory MP who's a Lieutenant Colonel called Moore Brabazon. there and the final one is the death sentence well so there's a lot of very pungent views floating around in the 1920s okay then in 1922 as people look abroad they suddenly see the emergence of a character who will be i would argue the single greatest inspiration to the british fascist movement and we'll find out who that is, Tom, after the break. See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余温》。我们正在研究英国法西斯主义，并试图探讨英国是否曾经转向法西斯主义的问题，多米尼克，我们谈到了成分都在那里，但当然你，你知道你需要一个烤箱，你需要一个食谱，
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at British fascism and trying to explore the question of whether britain might ever have turned fascist and dominic we were talking about the idea that the ingredients are there but of course you you know you need an oven and you need a recipe and
你需要有人来做这顿饭，我觉得这个隐喻正在螺旋式上升，这个隐喻刚才还在，坚持住，所以1920年代初，看向国外，英国人看到一位主厨在意大利出现，不是吗？他们确实看到了，所以那是墨索里尼，所以1922年是墨索里尼，他著名地，他没有向罗马进军，他让他的支持者为他向罗马进军，而他自己留在后面，但这已经商定好了，不是吗？它已经商定好了，正是如此，所以本质上，这是关于作秀，这是关于控制叙事，所有这类事情。我的意思是，意大利当然是另一个民主国家。有一个国王。有一个国王。而且英国有很多人，当墨索里尼上台时……所以首先，强调所有这些真的很重要。他们
you need someone to make the meal i feel this this metaphor is spiraling this metaphor was very earlier hold with me so in the early 1920s looking abroad the british see a master chef emerge in italy don't they they do so that's mussolini so 1922 is when mussolini he famously he doesn't march on rome he lets his supporters march on rome for him while he stays behind but it's already been agreed hadn't it it had been agreed exactly so essentially it's it's about showboating it's about control of the narrative, all that kind of thing. I mean, Italy, of course, is another democracy. With a king. With a king. And there are lots of people in Britain who, when Mussolini comes to power... So first of all, it's really important to emphasise with all of this. They
你需要有人来做这顿饭，我觉得这个比喻有点失控了，这个比喻在刚才就已经有点牵强了，跟我一起来看看，20世纪20年代初，英国人看向海外，看到意大利出现了一位主厨，对吧？确实如此，那就是墨索里尼，所以1922年墨索里尼上台，他最出名的是他并没有亲自进军罗马，而是让他的支持者替他进军罗马，而他自己则留在后方，但这一切其实早就商量好了，不是吗？确实早就商量好了，所以本质上这是一种作秀，是为了控制舆论，诸如此类。我的意思是，意大利当然是另一个民主国家，有一个国王，有一个国王，而且在英国有很多人，当墨索里尼上台时……所以首先，强调所有这些背景非常重要，他们
don't know what we know. They don't know where the story will lead. And of course, Mussolini is violent. They know that Mussolini is violent. They know that Mussolini is violent. But I mean, there are loads of people who admire the communists in the Soviet Union, and they're very violent. I mean, there are millions of people dying in the Russian Civil War. So when people, I think, read the stories about Mussolini's violence, about trade unionists being forced to drink castor oil or being beaten up or indeed killed, they may well think, oh gosh, shocking. But I don't think they think this is barbarism
不知道我们所知道的事情。他们不知道故事会走向何方。当然，墨索里尼是暴力的。他们知道墨索里尼是暴力的。他们知道墨索里尼是暴力的。但我的意思是，有很多人钦佩苏联的共产主义者，他们也非常暴力。我的意思是，在俄国内战中有数百万人死亡。所以当人们读到关于墨索里尼暴力的故事，比如工会成员被迫喝蓖麻油、被殴打甚至被杀害时，我想他们可能会觉得，天哪，太令人震惊了。但我不认为他们会认为这是野蛮行径。
beyond the scope of the human imagination. Also, there is a war going on in Ireland. And there have been paramilitary organisations in Ulster and in the rest of Ireland that have made the running and have torn a chunk out of the United Kingdom. So it's not like the idea of political violence is something alien to the British way of life. No, no, no. Of course, that's a very good point, actually. One thing we haven't really talked about is how a key part of fascism is paramilitary politics, but there's been lots of paramilitary politics in Britain in the last 20 years or so. The Ulster Volunteers, the paramilitary groups before the First World War, the Black and Tan, the use of the Black and Tan auxiliaries in Ireland. There are hundreds of thousands of demobilized officers, soldiers who miss the First World
超出了人类的想象范围。此外，爱尔兰正在发生战争。阿尔斯特和爱尔兰其他地区也出现了准军事组织，他们主导了局势，并从联合王国中撕裂了一块。所以，政治暴力的概念对英国人的生活方式来说并不陌生。不，不，不。当然，这确实是一个很好的观点。我们还没有真正讨论的一点是，法西斯主义的一个关键部分是准军事政治，但在过去20年左右的时间里，英国也有很多准军事政治。阿尔斯特志愿军，第一次世界大战前的准军事组织，黑棕部队，在爱尔兰使用黑棕辅助部队。有成千上万的复员军官、士兵错过了第一次世界
War, who feel bored, listless in the climate of the 1920s. This is the plot of the Bulldog Drum and Thrillers that I used to love when I was a boy, which are very, very anti-Semitic, very anti-Bolshevik, very paranoid. And they're about Bulldog Drummond as a guy who is drifting around, looking for a purpose. I mean, obviously this is Mussolini's appeal in Italy.
大战，他们在20世纪20年代的气候中感到无聊、无精打采。这就是我小时候喜欢读的《斗牛犬德拉蒙德》惊悚小说的情节，它们非常非常反犹太，非常反布尔什维克，非常偏执。它们讲述的是斗牛犬德拉蒙德作为一个四处漂泊、寻找目标的人的故事。我的意思是，这显然是墨索里尼在意大利的吸引力所在。
I think there are lots of people in Britain who think Mussolini is a tremendously impressive man who has actually given Italy a direction. He's anti-communist, all this stuff. So Sir Douglas Haig- The commander in the First World War. Commander in the First World War. Great celebrity in Britain. Much loved celebrity in Britain in the 1920s. He said of Mussolini, what a man. He really is exceptional. And that's actually typical. Go on, Tom. You're itching to say something. Well, I just wanted to put the counterpoint though,
我认为英国有很多人认为墨索里尼是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，他确实为意大利指明了方向。他是反共的，诸如此类。所以道格拉斯·黑格爵士——第一次世界大战的指挥官。第一次世界大战的指挥官。在英国享有盛誉。在20世纪20年代的英国是一位深受爱戴的名人。他评价墨索里尼说，真是个人物。他确实非常出色。这其实很典型。继续吧，汤姆。你急着想说什么。嗯，我只是想提出反面观点，
that the British regard the Italians as being somewhat comical and hysterical and prone to jumping up and down and waving their arms about. And in that sense, Mussolini does conform to that very negative stereotype. And fascism, the name that he gives to his movement, is a foreign movement. So is there also a sense that one of the reasons why fascism perhaps doesn't take off in Britain is that it's not a British invention? And the British are reluctant to adopt something that has been taken up by a comical people like the Italians as they see them. I think that's actually a very astute point. And it's one reason why Oswald Mosley in the 1930s was actually quite keen to downplay in public the associations with italian so they initially when he set up his movements in the
即英国人认为意大利人有点滑稽、歇斯底里，容易跳来跳去、挥舞手臂。从这个意义上说，墨索里尼确实符合那种非常负面的刻板印象。而法西斯主义，他给他的运动起的名字，是一个外来的运动。那么，法西斯主义在英国之所以没有流行起来，是否也是因为这不是英国的发明？英国人是否不愿采用像意大利人（在他们看来）那样滑稽的人所采用的东西？我认为这是一个非常敏锐的观点。这也是为什么奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利在20世纪30年代实际上非常热衷于在公开场合淡化与意大利的联系，所以他们最初在建立运动时，
1930s they use the fasces as a symbol and they ditch it for the kind of lightning bolt and he's always saying actually there's nothing alien about our ideas our ideas are true british political values so the emphasis on the king, which obviously is, I mean, there's a king in Italy, but they never talk about scrapping the monarchy. They always say the king will actually have more power in a fascist Britain because they want to reassure people. It's very Aragorn. Very Aragorn. Yes, very Aragorn. Of course, it's really important, two things. One,
20世纪30年代，他们使用束棒作为标志，后来又换成了闪电标志，他总是说，其实我们的思想没有什么外来的，我们的思想是真正的英国政治价值观，所以强调国王，这显然是，我的意思是，意大利也有国王，但他们从不谈论废除君主制。他们总是说，在法西斯英国，国王实际上会拥有更大的权力，因为他们想让人们放心。这非常像阿拉贡。非常像阿拉贡。是的，非常像阿拉贡。当然，这真的很重要，有两件事。第一，
Mussolini comes to power at the point when conservative unease about lloyd george is at its height so lloyd george is presiding over this coalition with a lot of the tory bigwigs and lots of grassroots tories think this is a massive stitch up by corrupt politicians which is obviously the idea that parliament has become corrupted and corroded and and all of you know it's just a talking shop of people feathering their own nest i I mean, you hear that all the time now, don't you? You do. And you hear conservatives now say, we've had a conservative government for however many years,
墨索里尼上台时，保守党对劳合·乔治的不安正处于顶峰，所以劳合·乔治正主持着这个与许多托利党大佬组成的联合政府，许多基层托利党人认为这是一场由腐败政客策划的巨大骗局，这显然是认为议会已经变得腐败和腐蚀，而且你们都知道，这只是人们为自己谋私利的清谈馆。我的意思是，你现在经常听到这种说法，不是吗？确实。而且你现在听到保守党人说，我们已经有了一个保守党政府这么多年了，
but it's not real conservatism. Which is exactly, exactly, Tom. I was thinking that a lot, actually, when I was reading about this, that there are parallels for now. There are lots of conservatives in the early 1920s who say, we've been in power for yonks, but actually Lloyd George obviously isn't a conservative. And our corrupt leaders colluding with his selling appearances.
但这并不是真正的保守主义。这正是，正是如此，汤姆。其实我在读到这些时，经常想到这一点，即现在也有相似之处。20世纪20年代初有很多保守党人说，我们执政已经很久了，但实际上劳合·乔治显然不是保守党人。我们腐败的领导人与他勾结，出卖了形象。
Giving the vote to all these flappers. Yeah, giving the vote to all these flappers to keep themselves in office. Whereas the true voice of the British patriot is being silenced. So there's that. And there's also the idea that Mussolini is a bulwark against communism. You cannot overstate the anxiety on the British right about Bolshevism in the 1920s. So you quoted from the Mail earlier on. The Mail is typical of lots of papers in Britain in the 1920s that look at Mussolini and they say, you know, a hard man, no doubt,
把投票权给了所有这些摩登女郎。是的，把投票权给了所有这些摩登女郎以保住自己的职位。而真正的英国爱国者的声音却被压制了。所以有这一点。还有一种观点认为墨索里尼是反对共产主义的堡垒。你无法夸大20世纪20年代英国右翼对布尔什维克主义的焦虑。所以你之前引用了《每日邮报》。《邮报》是20世纪20年代英国许多报纸的典型代表，他们看着墨索里尼说，你知道，毫无疑问，他是个硬汉，
but a really important shield against the advance of Bolshism. I mean, Winston Churchill famously, Churchill goes to Rome in 1927 and he says, I could not help being charmed by Signor Mussolini's gentle and simple bearing and by his calm, detached poise in spite of so many burdens and dangers. And then he says to Mussolini, if I'd been an Italian, I'm sure that I should have been wholeheartedly with you from start to finish in your triumphant struggle against the bestial appetites and perversions of Leninism. And there are loads of people who you can sort of see why Churchill would say that, Tom, because if you have that late Victorian imperial mindset, you quite like fighting. You like virility and all that stuff. Just to absolutely emphasise throughout this series that people did not know where it was
但确实是抵御布尔什维克主义推进的重要盾牌。我的意思是，温斯顿·丘吉尔很有名，丘吉尔在1927年去了罗马，他说，我无法不被墨索里尼先生温和而简单的举止，以及他在承受如此多负担和危险的情况下所表现出的冷静、超然的姿态所吸引。然后他对墨索里尼说，如果我是意大利人，我相信我一定会从头到尾全心全意地支持你，支持你反对列宁主义的兽性欲望和变态行为的胜利斗争。你可以看出为什么丘吉尔会那样说，汤姆，因为如果你有那种维多利亚晚期的帝国心态，你很喜欢战斗。你喜欢阳刚之气和所有这些东西。只是要绝对强调，在整个系列中，人们并不知道它
going to go. Today, fascism is an absolute bogey word because it is freighted with the blood of 6 million Jews killed in the Holocaust and countless million others killed in war and persecution. But at this point in the 1920s, that is all well in the future. It's really difficult, I think, when you have to try and think back into the shoes of people who don't know what's happening. I think, actually, this is really, really difficult because the very word fascism just seemed, you know, it smoulders with sulphur. I agree. But presumably, it doesn't have that inherent
会走向何方。今天，法西斯主义是一个绝对令人恐惧的词，因为它背负着大屠杀中600万犹太人的鲜血，以及战争和迫害中无数其他人的生命。但在20世纪20年代的这个时刻，这一切都还在未来。我认为，当你试图回到那些不知道正在发生什么的人的立场时，这真的很难。我认为，实际上，这真的非常非常困难，因为法西斯主义这个词本身似乎，你知道，它散发着硫磺味。我同意。但据推测，它并没有那种内在的
sulfurous quality. Well, remember that Mussolini at that point is not actually especially antisemitic. He's certainly no more antisemitic than many of the British people who admire him. And of course, he is violent. And of course, we look at Mussolini now and we say, what a disgusting man he was. Violent, rapacious, sexually predatory, bombastic, all these kinds of things. In the 1920s, the world has a lot of dictators. And if you'd said to people in Britain, where is the evil located? Which is the most blood-soaked, most frightening, threatening regime? I think a large proportion of them, not all of them, of course, but a large proportion would have said, unerringly, it's in Moscow.
硫磺味。嗯，记住墨索里尼在那个时候实际上并不是特别反犹太。他当然不比许多钦佩他的英国人更反犹太。当然，他是暴力的。当然，我们现在看墨索里尼，我们会说，他是一个多么令人作呕的人。暴力、贪婪、性掠夺、夸夸其谈，所有这些。在20世纪20年代，世界上有很多独裁者。如果你问英国人，邪恶在哪里？哪个政权最血腥、最可怕、最具威胁性？我想很大一部分人，当然不是全部，但很大一部分人会毫不犹豫地说，在莫斯科。
And anything that's fighting that, maybe by quite dirty methods, but anything that's fighting that, we should stand with them. I mean, there would have been a load of people who would have said that about Mussolini. Loads of the conservative middle classes, obviously lots of people in the aristocracy and so on. And so you start to get people who want to emulate Mussolini, and that's when you start to get the first British, genuine British fascists. Right. So you mentioned the aristocracy, and we talked about the Mitfords right at the start of the show. Notoriously, Jessica Mitford becomes a Stalinist and Unity Mitford becomes a Nazi. There is a sense in which there is an appeal on the extremes,
任何与之抗争的东西，也许手段相当肮脏，但任何与之抗争的东西，我们都应该支持他们。我的意思是，会有很多人会那样评价墨索里尼。很多保守派中产阶级，显然还有很多贵族等等。所以你开始看到有人想要效仿墨索里尼，那就是你开始看到第一批英国的、真正的英国法西斯分子的时候。对。所以你提到了贵族，我们在节目开始时谈到了米特福德家族。众所周知，杰西卡·米特福德成为了斯大林主义者，而尤妮蒂·米特福德成为了纳粹。在某种意义上，极端分子确实有吸引力，
isn't there? Yet in Britain, the centre does hold. It does hold. Obviously, there are communists in Britain. There's an emergent fascist movement in Britain as well. The 20s are a terrible decade marked by strikes and poverty and all kinds of things. But it doesn't go fascist. It doesn't go communist. Parliamentary democracy does hold. I think always the risk with doing an episode focused on fascism is that too big a concentration on it might lead us to over-egg it. Don't you think? I do think so.
不是吗？然而在英国，中间派确实稳住了。确实稳住了。显然，英国有共产主义者。英国也有一个新兴的法西斯运动。20年代是一个可怕的十年，充满了罢工、贫困和各种各样的事情。但它没有走向法西斯主义。它没有走向共产主义。议会民主制确实稳住了。我认为做一期专注于法西斯主义的节目，总是存在一种风险，即过于集中讨论它可能会导致我们夸大其词。你不觉得吗？我确实这么认为。
You could say, Tom, and lots of people have been calling for this podcast for a long time, so you could say that actually this whole series on British fascism is actually a disguised series about Stanley Baldwin. Yeah. So Stanley Baldwin, who becomes Conservative leader, who's the Prime Minister three times in the interwar years, who is the man who brings down Lloyd George in 1922. He makes a speech at the Carlton Club to the Tories and says, Lloyd George is corrupt.
你可以说，汤姆，很多人长期以来一直呼吁做这个播客，所以你可以说，实际上整个关于英国法西斯主义的系列节目，实际上是一个关于斯坦利·鲍德温的伪装系列。是的。所以斯坦利·鲍德温，他成为了保守党领袖，在两次世界大战之间担任了三次首相，他是1922年推翻劳合·乔治的人。他在卡尔顿俱乐部对托利党人发表讲话，说劳合·乔治是腐败的。
He's a dynamic force who will crush us, who will destroy us if we don't get rid of him. Baldwin, who sort of presents himself as the soul of the British middle classes and of kind of middle England, he actually, his emollient political persona, the way in which he's prepared actually to make space for the newly emerging Labour Party and then actually to work with people from the Labour Party in the 1930s. You could argue that the defeat of fascism is a victory for a very unglamorous, mundane, suburban Baldwinism. And to some extent, Ramsay MacDonald, the leader of the Labour Party. So the centre does hold, as you say, and it holds in part because Britain actually has some, I think, contrary to the stereotype of the interwar years, Britain actually has some quite good politicians
他是一股充满活力的力量，如果我们不除掉他，他会压垮我们，会摧毁我们。鲍德温，他把自己表现为英国中产阶级和英国中部的灵魂，他实际上，他那温和的政治形象，他准备为新出现的工党腾出空间，然后在20世纪30年代与工党的人合作的方式。你可以说，法西斯主义的失败是某种非常平庸、世俗、郊区的鲍德温主义的胜利。在某种程度上，还有工党领袖拉姆齐·麦克唐纳。所以正如你所说，中间派确实稳住了，而且在某种程度上稳住了，因为英国实际上有一些——我认为，与两次世界大战之间的刻板印象相反——英国实际上有一些相当不错的政治家，
who know what the public want, who are building houses, who are doing their best to keep the economy on track, even though the economy is a complete and utter mess. And of course, Britain hasn't been humiliated in the First World War. It's come out of the First World War financially much weaker, but it actually has more colonies than it started with. So people don't feel the burning resentment and victimhood that they did in Germany. Having said all that, on the fringes, fascism is taking hold in Britain. I mean, it's absolutely a minority pursuit, right? But it is taking root. So to go back to what you were saying about how hard it is to think ourselves back into this
他们知道公众想要什么，他们正在建造房屋，他们正在尽最大努力让经济走上正轨，尽管经济是一团糟。当然，英国在第一次世界大战中没有受到羞辱。它从第一次世界大战中走出来时，财政上要弱得多，但它实际上拥有的殖民地比开始时更多。所以人们没有像在德国那样感到强烈的怨恨和受害者心态。话虽如此，在边缘地带，法西斯主义正在英国扎根。我的意思是，这绝对是少数人的追求，对吧？但它确实在扎根。所以回到你刚才说的关于回到那个时刻有多难，
moment, when you read about the very first fascist groups, it's actually very difficult to see them as terribly sinister because they're just absolutely comical and eccentric. So the very first one, the British Fascisti, was founded in May 1923 by somebody who, in such a 1920s way, she was called the Man Woman. Her name was Rota Lintorn Orman. So many of the people in this story, by the way, have military connections. So she's the granddaughter of Field Marshal Sir John Linton Simmons. Before the First World War, Rota Lintorn Orman had been absolutely passionate about the Scouts she'd joined
当你读到最初的法西斯组织时，实际上很难把他们看作是非常险恶的，因为他们只是绝对的滑稽和古怪。所以第一个，英国法西斯党，是由某个人在1923年5月创立的，她以一种非常20世纪20年代的方式，被称为“男人婆”。她的名字叫罗塔·林托恩·奥曼。顺便说一句，这个故事中的许多人都有军事背景。所以她是约翰·林顿·西蒙斯元帅的孙女。在第一次世界大战之前，罗塔·林托恩·奥曼就对童子军非常热衷，她加入了
the Girl Scouts in 1909 very early and she'd founded and led her own troop in Bournemouth come on girls yeah
1909年的女童子军，非常早，并且她在伯恩茅斯创立并领导了自己的小队。来吧，女孩们，是的。
South Coast by the way she liked that I don't imagine her having that deeper voice to be honest like Mrs Trunchbull but she was born in 1895 Tom
顺便说一句，南海岸，她喜欢那个。老实说，我不认为她有那种低沉的声音，就像特朗奇布尔夫人一样，但她出生于1895年，汤姆。
so she was a teenager at this point so she wouldn't have spoken like that. I think she's posh. Come on, girls. Yes, I think she's posher. Then in the First World War, she serves a tremendous distinction.
所以她当时还是个十几岁的孩子，所以她不会那样说话。我认为她很时髦。来吧，女孩们。是的，我认为她更时髦。然后在第一次世界大战中，她表现得非常出色。
She works in Serbia with the Scottish Women's Hospital Corps. She's a commandant in the British Red Cross Motor School. There are lots of women, by the way, who love the First World War, who really get stuck in. It gives them opportunities, a chance to do things that in normal life they wouldn't be able to do. She loves wearing military dress. She loves just hanging around with women, doing stuff, not being high bound by the Edwardian conventions. She comes back from the war. Like so many people, she thinks nothing is going to be as good again. She goes off to a dairy farm in
她在塞尔维亚的苏格兰妇女医院工作。她是英国红十字会汽车学校的指挥官。顺便说一句，有很多女性热爱第一次世界大战，她们真的全身心投入。这给了她们机会，一个在正常生活中无法做到的事情的机会。她喜欢穿军装。她喜欢和女性在一起，做事情，不受爱德华时代传统的束缚。她从战争中回来。像许多人一样，她认为再也没有什么会像以前那样好了。她去了萨默塞特的一个奶牛场。
Somerset. This is an amazing story. One day, she's weeding her garden when she has a revelation, Tom, like a divine revelation. I know you love a divine revelation. I don't think this is divine, but she has a revelation about the terrible threat being posed to Britain by Bolsheviks, socialists, and foreigners. How does this revelation come? I think she's just weeding. Weeding is quite boring. Well, but a weeding is you're cleaning your garden. You're getting rid of- There's a metaphor there, isn't there? Yeah, there is a metaphor there.
这是一个惊人的故事。有一天，她在花园里除草时，突然有了启示，汤姆，就像神圣的启示。我知道你喜欢神圣的启示。我不认为这是神圣的，但她对布尔什维克、社会主义者和外国人对英国构成的可怕威胁有了启示。这种启示是怎么来的？我想她只是在除草。除草很无聊。嗯，但除草是你清理花园。你在摆脱——那里有一个隐喻，不是吗？是的，有一个隐喻。
So she thinks, and she's obviously read about Masui, and she thinks, do you know what? I'll do it. No one else has done it. I'll do it. And so she sets up this movement, the British Fashisti. She gets another ex-military person who's a man, Brigadier General Robert Blakeney. He'd been the general manager of the Egyptian State Railway. And he comes in, he says, I'll run the organization for you, Mr. Linda Norman. He says, this is basically the grown-up version of the Boy Scout movement. He says, like the Scouts, we uphold the same lofty ideals
所以她想，而且她显然读过关于墨索里尼的事，她想，你知道吗？我会做的。没有其他人做过。我会做的。于是她建立了这个运动，英国法西斯党。她找了另一个前军人，一个男人，罗伯特·布莱克尼准将。他曾是埃及国家铁路的总经理。他进来了，他说，我会为你管理这个组织，林托恩·奥曼小姐。他说，这基本上是童子军运动的成人版。他说，像童子军一样，我们坚持同样的崇高理想，
of brotherhood, service, and duty. And the people that pile in, I say pile in, both of the people that pile in, all 10 of them, you know, both of the people that pile in. All 10 of them. They are military people or landed gentry or aristocracy. So they are Brigadier General Sir Ormond Winter, Brigadier General Erskine Tulloch, Colonel Sir Charles Byrne MP, Admiral John Armstrong. Is there a sense that often these are people who've come back from lengthy service, maybe in the war, or maybe in the colonies, and they come back to Britain and they find that it's full of flappers and lesbians.
兄弟情谊、服务和责任。而涌入的人，我说涌入，涌入的两个人，所有10个人，你知道，涌入的两个人。所有10个人。他们是军人、地主或贵族。所以他们是奥蒙德·温特准将、厄斯金·塔洛赫准将、查尔斯·伯恩上校议员、约翰·阿姆斯特朗海军上将。是否有一种感觉，即这些人往往是刚从长期服役中回来的人，也许是在战争中，也许是在殖民地，他们回到英国，发现这里到处都是摩登女郎和女同性恋者。
Yes, there is absolutely that sense, Tom. That, again, you mentioned John Buchan. Country's going to the dogs. How often does that happen at the beginning of a John Buchan book in the 1920s? Yes, coming back from Natal. Yeah. I've been out on the veldt. I sat there in London.
是的，绝对有那种感觉，汤姆。那，你再次提到了约翰·布肯。国家正在走向毁灭。在20世纪20年代的约翰·布肯书中，这种情况多久发生一次？是的，从纳塔尔回来。是的。我在草原上。我坐在伦敦。
Big game hunting. I'm feeling very seedy i looked at the young men walking none of them had shot a you know an elephant into the eye yeah yeah they're all communists and jews yeah that is exactly limp-wristed exactly that is floating around in the popular culture of the 20s and all these people i mean the earl of glasgow some of these people you just think they've been made up. Earl Temple of Stowe, the Marquess of Aylesbury, Lord de Clifford. So a lot of aristocrats. A lot of aristocrats. And I suppose the other thing, Dominic, that's happening with the aristocracy
大型狩猎。我感觉很糟糕，我看着走过的年轻人，他们中没有人射中过（你知道）大象的眼睛。是的，是的，他们都是共产主义者和犹太人。是的，这正是那种软弱无力的感觉，这在20年代的流行文化中到处都是，所有这些人，我的意思是格拉斯哥伯爵，其中一些人你只是觉得他们是编出来的。斯托的坦普尔伯爵，艾尔斯伯里侯爵，德克利福德勋爵。所以很多贵族。很多贵族。我想另一件事，多米尼克，正在发生在贵族身上，
is that with Lloyd George, who has famously, what was it, dukes cost more than dreadnoughts, that the primordial hold on the land and power that the hereditary aristocracy had always had is now under attack. Absolutely right. If you're a duke, your life as you see it, perceive it, is in ruins. You can't get good servants anymore. Your house is crippled by taxes. Papa died five years ago and the death duties are unbelievable. You're paying high income tax. You don't even believe in income tax at all. You've lost your house in Ireland where you used to go fishing. Your daughter has become a lesbian flapper.
那就是劳合·乔治，他有一句名言，公爵比无畏舰更昂贵，世袭贵族一直拥有的对土地和权力的原始控制权现在受到了攻击。绝对正确。如果你是一个公爵，你所看到的、感知到的生活已经毁了。你再也雇不到好的仆人了。你的房子被税收压垮了。爸爸五年前去世了，遗产税高得令人难以置信。你正在支付高额所得税。你甚至根本不相信所得税。你失去了在爱尔兰钓鱼的房子。你的女儿变成了一个女同性恋摩登女郎。
All of this kind of stuff. It's all very familiar. Yeah, and these people just think we've lost our political power forever because the Tory party, which is meant to be our party, is led by this bloody awful middle-class Baldwin. yeah baldwin who's practically a socialist so all these people are drawn to the to the british fascisti there's also people who just like fighting so the most famous example of that is a man who we would definitely be talking about a fair bit who is a man called william joyce so he will be best known to people as lord horhor so lord horhor was this guy who was broadcasting
所有这些事情。这都很熟悉。是的，这些人只是认为我们永远失去了政治权力，因为保守党，本应是我们的党，却由这个该死的、糟糕的中产阶级鲍德温领导。是的，鲍德温，他几乎是个社会主义者。所以所有这些人被吸引到英国法西斯党，还有一些人只是喜欢打架，所以最著名的例子是一个我们肯定会多谈谈的人，他叫威廉·乔伊斯，所以他最广为人知的名字是“霍霍勋爵”。所以“霍霍勋爵”就是那个在第二次世界大战期间向英国广播
german propaganda to britain during the second world war and ended up spoiler alert being executed for it he was nicknamed lord horhor because of the sort of strangulated faux contrived aristocratic way that he spoke but william Joyce was actually born in Ireland to a kind of a unionist, loyalist family. He moved to England with his family after Britain got out of what becomes ultimately the Republic of Ireland. He had been associated with the Black and Tans. He comes to Dulwich in South London. He feels that he's been cheated. Well, Dulwich, notorious breeding ground of very right-wing people. Nigel Farage went to school.
德国宣传，最后——剧透警告——因此被处决的人。他被称为“霍霍勋爵”，因为他说话时那种扭曲的、虚假的、刻意的贵族腔调。但威廉·乔伊斯实际上出生在爱尔兰的一个联合派、效忠派家庭。在英国撤出最终成为爱尔兰共和国的地区后，他随家人搬到了英格兰。他曾与黑棕部队有关联。他来到伦敦南部的达利奇。他觉得他被骗了。嗯，达利奇，非常右翼人士的臭名昭著的滋生地。奈杰尔·法拉奇去过那里的学校。
Nigel Farage. As did P.G. Woodhouse, Tom. And P.G. Woodhouse, of course. And Raymond Chandler. Really? Did Raymond Chandler go to Dulwich? Or did he teach at Dulwich? He went to Dulwich College.
奈杰尔·法拉奇。P.G.伍德豪斯也去过，汤姆。当然还有P.G.伍德豪斯。还有雷蒙德·钱德勒。真的吗？雷蒙德·钱德勒去过达利奇吗？还是他在达利奇教书？他去了达利奇学院。
Did he? He was there with P.G. Woodhouse, yeah. Do you know, I didn't know that. Yeah. An amazing Dulwich College fact. That is a very good fact. I love a public school fact, Tom, as you know. I know you do so uh william joyce he joins the british fascisti and he likes going
是吗？他和P.G.伍德豪斯在那里，是的。你知道吗，我不知道。是的。一个惊人的达利奇学院事实。这是一个非常好的事实。我知道你喜欢公立学校的事实，汤姆。我知道你喜欢，所以呃威廉·乔伊斯他加入了英国法西斯党，他喜欢去
and fighting communists in the streets so breaking up communist meetings and all this kind of thing and the british fascisti they end up calling themselves the british fascists because they realize they call themselves the fascist foreign doesn't it does sound a little bit foreign yeah they hold meetings in in birmingham in hy Park, and they will draw up to 5,000 people. So not huge, but not nothing. What's interesting is that even at this point, they're a particular stronghold. So it won't surprise anybody given how many retired colonels we've been impersonating. And the South Coast, South Coast Resorts is a good place. The cities, London, Birmingham, and so on. What's also interesting is there's a big overlap.
在街上和共产主义者打架，所以破坏共产主义者的会议等等。英国法西斯党最终称自己为“英国法西斯分子”，因为他们意识到他们称自己为“法西斯”听起来有点外国，不是吗？确实听起来有点外国。是的，他们在伯明翰、海德公园举行会议，他们会吸引多达5000人。所以不是很多，但也不是没有。有趣的是，即使在这一点上，他们也有一个特定的据点。所以考虑到我们一直在模仿多少退休上校，这不会让任何人感到惊讶。南海岸，南海岸度假胜地是一个好地方。城市，伦敦，伯明翰等等。同样有趣的是，有一个很大的重叠。
Glasgow as well, I gather. Glasgow, yeah. Glasgow has this sectarian politics, doesn't it? It also has a sizable professional middle class who might vote conservative. There is a big overlap between British fascists, actually not just the British fascisti, but also going right into the 1930s, there is an absolute overlap with the conservatives. So a lot of these people would also be members of the Conservative Party. Indeed, the British fascisti tell their members at elections, they don't stand for election. They say at elections, you should vote conservative and you should always be loyal to king and country.
格拉斯哥也是，我收集到。格拉斯哥，是的。格拉斯哥有这种宗派政治，不是吗？它也有一个相当大的专业中产阶级，他们可能会投票给保守党。英国法西斯分子之间有一个很大的重叠，实际上不仅仅是英国法西斯党，而且一直持续到20世纪30年代，与保守党有绝对的重叠。所以这些人中的许多人也会是保守党成员。事实上，英国法西斯党在选举时告诉他们的成员，他们不参加选举。他们在选举时说，你应该投票给保守党，你应该永远忠于国王和国家。
And there are Tory MPs like this guy, a Birmingham MP. Another MP, he's an MP until 1950 called Patrick Hannan. He is on the fascist grand council. He hosts British fascist dinners in Birmingham. He books House of Commons rooms for fascist meetings. And he sees no conflict between being a regular conservative MP and being a member of the British fascists. So it's a bit like being a Freemason or something. Yeah, I think that's pretty much right. Now we're going to run out of time. So just on these very early fascists, what's really interesting is that it was set up by a woman. And I think women are, from the very beginning, very prominent in the fascist movement. So like all sort of fringe
而且有托利党议员像这个家伙，一个伯明翰议员。另一个议员，他直到1950年都是议员，叫帕特里克·汉南。他在法西斯大委员会。他在伯明翰举办英国法西斯晚宴。他为法西斯会议预订下议院房间。他认为作为一个普通的保守党议员和一个英国法西斯党成员之间没有冲突。所以这有点像共济会之类的。是的，我认为这基本正确。现在我们要没时间了。所以关于这些非常早期的法西斯分子，真正有趣的是它是由一个女人建立的。而且我认为女性从一开始就在法西斯运动中非常突出。所以像所有那种边缘
extremist movements, it splits quite quickly. So by 1924, we're saying it'll be going a year, by 1924, there's another group called the National Fascisti. They are more militant. They think of the British Fascist sellouts. Maybe they're part of the conspiracy. The National Fascisti only have 60 members, but one of them, Tom, is somebody I know you're very keen to talk about on the podcast. You're very keen to come back to her, so we won't give away all her story.
极端运动一样，它分裂得很快。所以到1924年，我们说它已经进行了一年，到1924年，有另一个组织叫“国家法西斯党”。他们更激进。他们认为英国法西斯党是卖国贼。也许他们是阴谋的一部分。国家法西斯党只有60名成员，但其中一个，汤姆，是某个人，我知道你非常想在播客上谈论她。你非常想回到她身边，所以我们不会透露她所有的故事。
She is a woman called Valerie Arkell-Smith, who at various points trades as Sir Victor Barker, Colonel Barker, and Captain Barker. A great enthusiast for boxing. Yeah. And she likes the name Barker, I think it's fair to say. So she is a character, it's fair to say. She's from the Channel Islands. She ends up marrying a woman called Elfrida, who believes that she's a man. Valerie Arkel-Smith tells her, my name is Victor Barker, and I've been very badly injured in the Great War. War wound. Very like Downton Abbey. So if you spot any unexpected physical characteristics, this is because of my injuries in the First World War. They get married and they live in Brighton. And at some point in 1926, Valerie Arkell Smith, aka Sir Victor Barker, she sees a letter addressed to somebody called Barker.
她是一个叫瓦莱丽·阿克尔-史密斯的女人，她在不同时期以维克多·巴克爵士、巴克上校和巴克船长的身份交易。一个拳击的狂热爱好者。是的。而且她喜欢巴克这个名字，我认为这样说是公平的。所以她是一个人物，这样说是公平的。她来自海峡群岛。她最终嫁给了一个叫埃尔弗里达的女人，她认为自己是一个男人。瓦莱丽·阿克尔-史密斯告诉她，我的名字是维克多·巴克，我在大战中受了重伤。战争创伤。非常像《唐顿庄园》。所以如果你发现任何意想不到的身体特征，这是因为我在第一次世界大战中的伤。他们结婚了，住在布莱顿。在1926年的某个时候，瓦莱丽·阿克尔-史密斯，又名维克多·巴克爵士，她看到一封寄给叫巴克的人的信。
And it's actually not to her. And it's from the National Fascisti. Thank you for inquiring about membership. You are member 6423 or whatever. And she thinks, oh, I'll join. So she ends up joining the National Fashisti. So Dominic, I think that that is an amazing teaser for an episode because, spoiler alert, Colonel Barker ends up as a fairground attraction in Blackpool alongside the vicar of Stuky
实际上不是给她的。而且是来自国家法西斯党。感谢您询问会员资格。您是会员6423还是什么的。她想，哦，我会加入。所以她最终加入了国家法西斯党。所以多米尼克，我认为这是一个非常棒的剧集预告，因为——剧透警告——巴克上校最终成为了布莱克浦的一个游乐场景点，和斯塔基的牧师在一起，
who ends up being eaten by a lion. So we're going to do an episode on Britain's two top fairground attractions. So he, she will be part of that. All right, Tom. so we're going to do an episode on Britain's two top fairground attractions so he she will be part of that alright Tom you're fascinated by this story but also
他最终被狮子吃了。所以我们将做一期关于英国两大顶级游乐场景点的节目。所以他/她将成为其中的一部分。好吧，汤姆。所以我们将做一期关于英国两大顶级游乐场景点的节目，所以他/她将成为其中的一部分。好吧，汤姆，你对这个故事很着迷，但也
because we're running out of time I want you to give a chance to talk about this guy who has something to do with camels you put down camels
因为我们没时间了，我想让你有机会谈谈这个和骆驼有关的家伙。你写下了骆驼。
so one mother Spencer group that is formed is called the Imperial Fascist League that was founded in 1928 are you familiar
所以成立的另一个母亲斯宾塞组织被称为“帝国法西斯联盟”，成立于1928年。你熟悉吗
with them Tom Tom? No. Great. So there's a guy called Arnold Spencer Lease. He's a vet. He's an experienced vet. He's an expert on camels. He'd been investigating camel diseases before the First World War. He is the world expert on the health of camels. His book, his masterwork was published the same year he set up the Imperial Fascist League. And his masterwork, it's a better read, I think it's fair to say, than Mein Kampf. It's called A Treatise on the One-Humped Camel in Health and Disease. Oh, is it still used?
他们，汤姆？不。太好了。所以有一个叫阿诺德·斯宾塞·里斯的家伙。他是一名兽医。他是一位经验丰富的兽医。他是骆驼方面的专家。他在第一次世界大战前一直在研究骆驼疾病。他是骆驼健康方面的世界专家。他的书，他的杰作，在他成立帝国法西斯联盟的同一年出版。而他的杰作，我认为比《我的奋斗》更好读。它叫《单峰骆驼的健康与疾病论》。哦，它还在用吗？
I mean, he was absolutely the top man in the world on one-humped camels. Oh, but he was also a fascist. But he was also a fascist. He had been reading all of this anti-Semitic stuff in the 1910s, 1920s. He believed that British aristocracy was being corrupted by Jews because they'd married Jewish heiresses. I'll give you an example of that. And this also is relating back to some episodes that we've just been doing, namely the Oscar Wilde trial, in which the Prime Minister, Lord Rosebery, appeared. And he had married Hannah Rothschild, a fabulously wealthy heiress and of course Jewish. And their son, Lord Dalmany, when he was born, Rosebery apparently said,
我的意思是，他绝对是世界上单峰骆驼方面的顶尖人物。哦，但他也是一个法西斯分子。但他也是一个法西斯分子。他在1910年代、1920年代一直在读所有这些反犹太的东西。他认为英国贵族正在被犹太人腐蚀，因为他们娶了犹太女继承人。我会给你一个例子。这也与我们刚刚做的一些剧集有关，即奥斯卡·王尔德审判，其中首相罗斯伯里勋爵出现了。他娶了汉娜·罗斯柴尔德，一位极其富有的女继承人，当然也是犹太人。当他们的儿子达尔梅尼勋爵出生时，罗斯伯里显然说，
oh, he looks Jewish and hated him from that point on. But this didn't stop Lord Dalmany from becoming both an MP and captain of Surrey County Cricket Club and leading them to victory in the championship. And it was Lord Dalmany who got the Prince of Wales to agree that they could have the ostrich feathers, which were the symbol of the Prince of Wales, which we talked about in our Hundred Years War episode. So everything connects to serve as the emblem for Surrey County Cricket Club. But I mentioned that because this was an example of the kind of the paranoia around the aristocracy. Yeah. That ancient British titles,
哦，他看起来像犹太人，从那时起就讨厌他。但这并没有阻止达尔梅尼勋爵成为议员和萨里郡板球俱乐部队长，并带领他们赢得了冠军。正是达尔梅尼勋爵让威尔士亲王同意他们可以使用鸵鸟羽毛，这是威尔士亲王的象征，我们在我们的百年战争剧集中谈到过。所以一切都连接起来，作为萨里郡板球俱乐部的标志。但我提到这一点是因为这是围绕贵族的偏执的一个例子。是的。那些古老的英国头衔，
that they were marrying Jewish heiresses and therefore the aristocracy was being corrupted was the point of view of the... Arnold Lees would not have enjoyed watching Surrey Cricket Club then, Tom. It's fair to say. No. Buried himself in his book on the cameras.
他们娶了犹太女继承人，因此贵族正在被腐蚀，这是……的观点。阿诺德·里斯当时肯定不喜欢看萨里板球俱乐部的比赛，汤姆。这样说是公平的。不。埋头于他的骆驼书里。
But if you were a Surrey fan, absolutely you would, as I am. So, Rafa Lord Dalmany. So the imperial fasc fascists they dress in very extravagant uniforms they have a black shirt black shirt tom that's going to anticipate something to come they have khaki breeches and they wear putties they wear a beret and a cummerbund which i think is i think no movement would ever come to power in britain wearing berets and cummerbunds personally well they see you have your PG Woodhouse, their comic. Yes, I do. I mean, they're sinister because they're very anti-Semitic,
但如果你是萨里队的球迷，你绝对会，就像我一样。所以，拉法·达尔梅尼勋爵。所以帝国法西斯分子他们穿着非常奢华的制服，他们有黑衬衫，黑衬衫，汤姆，那将预示着即将到来的事情，他们有卡其色马裤，他们穿绑腿，他们戴贝雷帽和腰带，我认为，我认为没有运动会在英国掌权时戴贝雷帽和腰带，个人而言。嗯，你看，你有你的P.G.伍德豪斯，他们滑稽。是的，我确实有。我的意思是，他们很险恶，因为他们非常反犹太，
the imperial fascist elite, but there are not many of them. And I think it's fair to say, you get to the end of the 1920s, the general strike has happened, all kinds of kind of political and economic turbulence, but they have got absolutely nowhere. The system is too resilient. And also they lack what all successful fascist movements have, which is a really convincing, charismatic, articulate, plausible front man. So the camel vet is not going to cut it. Nor is Sir Victor Barker with his war wound or her war wound. But then, Tom, at the beginning of the 1930s, they find an extremely plausible front man. In some degree, you might say the perfect front man with a war record, with aristocratic links, a brilliant speaker, a man who comes, would you believe, from the Labour Party.
帝国法西斯精英，但他们人数不多。我认为这样说是公平的，你到了20世纪20年代末，大罢工已经发生，各种各样的政治和经济动荡，但他们绝对一事无成。系统太有弹性了。而且他们缺乏所有成功的法西斯运动所拥有的东西，那就是一个真正令人信服、有魅力、口才好、合理的门面人物。所以骆驼兽医是不行的。维克多·巴克爵士和他的战争创伤也不行。但后来，汤姆，在20世纪30年代初，他们找到了一个极其合理的门面人物。在某种程度上，你可能会说是一个完美的门面人物，有战争记录，有贵族联系，一个出色的演讲者，一个来自，你敢相信吗，工党的人。
And that is Sir Oswald Mosley. And we'll tell that story next time. Well, that's brilliant, Dominic. What a cliffhanger. And if you simply can't bear to wait for that and the other two episodes that we'll be recording after that, so Mitford's, Cable Street, all kinds of things to come, then you can listen to them straight away by joining the Rest Is History Club. But if you don't want to do that then that's fine they will be coming out on thursday and then next week so we will see you either immediately if you're a member of the rest is history club or on thursday thank you dominic and thank you all for listening bye-bye
那就是奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利爵士。我们下次会讲那个故事。嗯，那太棒了，多米尼克。真是个悬念。如果你实在等不及那一集以及我们之后要录制的另外两集——所以米特福德家族、缆车街，各种各样的事情即将到来——那么你可以通过加入“历史就是其余”俱乐部立即收听。但如果你不想那样做，那也没关系，它们将在周四发布，然后是下周，所以我们会在周四见，或者如果你是“历史就是其余”俱乐部的成员，我们会立即见。谢谢你，多米尼克，也谢谢大家的收听。再见。
bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持“娱乐就是其余”。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持“娱乐就是其余”。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。